you
you
you
yeah hello and welcome to a Monday Night
Live show I hope you hear me well see me
well I needed to do some software
changes but yeah I feel it should work
fine okay let's get ganger all started
oh that's a tough opponent form from the
start when last the shade I don't know
who that is what is reasonably high
rated well same I think I'll go for my
for my old she go and I know that people
hate it when I do it but one thing I
know is that I have a really really
really long experience with this and I
can't play with Noda quickly sound any
sound issues is there no sound okay
assault seems okay the Shiv h6 is a
common in extra see them it's not a big
deal still loses a temple it's after
night f70 has to go back not a big deal
as I mentioned this one yeah this is an
extremely close position something
interesting is that so it's interesting
that he never played a form
try for Bishop h6 which he prevented
okay I can try to insist on it with
Bishop g7 Queen f8 Bishop h6 I've
actually have gotten that somebody says
sound dissolve Wow
I mean either nobody has found all your
all F sound it shouldn't depend on some
sort of setting so little bit too bit
strange he tries to get h4 in it's not
so easy with the bishop looking at the
g4 pawn
night can retreat I came still AM I've
got Bishop h6 lined up
and a man on the clock this is the
outside if you play the same line really
really often like I have done with this
you can actually justify the question
how good it is but I can tell you that I
have played it a million times and I can
usually play moves good claim okay so
when you have I can from the take win a
fall I don't know Queen a4 is probably
not such a great idea
Queen s very little squares so what to
do on h5 I can go g5 this is clear
g5 I can take this case let's and get to
school back we just that I fail this is
totally totally safe for me
surprising me I mean he can play for and
so on but this isn't really a big deal I
thought
okay so allows me to take their you
scored 90 for it I don't really see what
this does
no I shouldn't do this for me not night
a six
night a 60-watt slay I probably take now
I can still be tricky somewhat
oh nice before I want to have this ship
a six this is what I want to do
yes it's a completely dead position of
course but I'm a little bit behind on
time okay can try to sacrifice valid 96
time warning check it's a total draw
graph offered 97 million
[Music]
at night at 2:00 for a moment that
actually doesn't matter at least I don't
think so
I've landed it unnecessarily but don't
think it matters much check check check
black for fit on time I am ah this is
just what happens in this ridiculous
time control without increment oh yeah
it is still wrong the whole game but
anyway
next game and that happens sometimes of
course in this opening it is it has
those long games and known sometimes if
you fall behind on the clock it can be
tricky of course add chances em I could
have won an exchange a couple of time
very nice game though White's don't
freak out you're this you're this
spammer Gaea I remember your name on my
channel always posting idiotic comments
that's cool I am anyway so I have a new
game week without game started really
corner with black so let's see play a
different line down makes you want it to
play g6 but that is also interesting 97
or 96
yeah vas means I was quite slow down
that's true experimenting you with this
I don't think I'm playing this right
yeah with nige 87
let's see if we trades no I'm preparing
a five and this is a lot like a king
than Jana just the piece placement is a
little bit different
g4 I have a good Logitech mouse but my
research writer I mean I can this is
like a 60 euro Mouse I mean I can get
something else but I think it's
reasonably okay I mean I just don't play
blitz at the moment now sometimes do
play bullets but not often at the moment
so it's that really good for white it
looks a bit strange to open this
position like he does Knight h4 maybe
can also take somehow this looks a bit
strange with this with the king sitting
there I have a mechanical keyboard young
and I teach for I dunno if it helps all
that much
Queen f6 that doesn't help
Queenie eight maybe for Queen age five
could be energy M
tough positional not easy
I try queen h5m yes so queen h5 what is
the deal I can also take care first and
then Queen h5
let's do it
simply threatening to take III and h3
Queen f3 is also a threat immediately
but not the biggest issue maybe it is an
issue but 93 is the simpler threat yeah
this was to be expected the question is
can I do something better than just
trading Queens which isn't bad
just the ending isn't bad but I wondered
I am
very more interesting right that's a
question of I think that if there are
any benefits to playing chess960 you
mean like benefits for for for regular
games let's say no I don't think so I
don't think it's in any way wrong or bad
but I don't think you have any any any
big benefit okay so I can check here
take there that doesn't do much 94 is an
option
maybe I'm intending night a three chick
and I don't think he he wants to take
the night
and also sometimes I can just take take
taking one see - it looks uncomfortable
for widest position
okay so what to do night before doesn't
do much
he has weakened everything here
basically but I don't see a direct way
to exploit it stubble them I mean it's a
bit lame maybe but didn't find anything
grade and Bishop takes default allowed
me Bishop e5 always I don't know okay
second hook
okay Knight f3 is almost on but I can go
here and then I'm attacking f3 like a
million times and now it takes it okay
you should be 5 is now on so we should
be 5 check and I can take h3 actually I
don't see why not
ok time warning
I have this check and route g7 I have
actually overlooked this move okay
before night is hanging though channel
is caught this check I don't believe
this
come on this is crazy this is crazy
check now he blunders stuff back check
really completely check bonkers so how
to how to do it I've got 6 seconds check
my blunder into friggin mate yet
absolutely possible
like 4 fix on time what a crazy game
there I just are you white got
completely killed and then i blundered
it back and he blundered it back what a
weird game ok game started ok mr. Keeney
on it's one of the frequent opponents
Carlo de Moura de Moura let's let the
48th game and I'm leading by one point
22 wins 21 losses for draws so we have a
draw percentage of and yeah hey low very
low 5 to center I guess okay so he wants
to go with 5 it seems deal I think he is
always playing extremely ambitious moves
if they work or not often they're good
but sometimes they just extremely
ambitious has not warranted and is this
kind of stuff maybe it's good maybe not
and better than I didn't even think
about okay and even taking 1 1 X 7 as an
idea Bishop g5 95 g5 he will take the
one g3 I mean it gets wacky
and we'll be working
okay so I just take here right just an
extremely strange position but DTX
isn't that just good why isn't that just
good white and he's like firing on
firing everyone everything that he has
let me just take it G takes is that the
idea maybe it is and I go here right
help I need somebody help Queen b6 I
have Bishop d4 I don't get it
this is what I meant yeah he plays the
most ambitious stuff ever and it
sometimes it works like like genius or
it just doesn't work at all
we're done this is one of those I don't
get it
games I still have a somewhat somewhat
shaky King position so it's really too
early to and to think it's over
Luke c7 I might take here yeah and then
then check then check me
Quinn you won maybe
to stern cover this stuff yeah so I
would like to play this actively and not
cover stuff like this Luke take
screening for watching check check check
it should be good
my ideas to just the text and take
myself on f7 and don't defend I mean
this is the extra piece not 25 shouldn't
allow 25 on how to do it here and
without blundering everything Queen f6
maybe or something am I so I feel like I
could so blunder away it would something
stupid
I was thinking Quincy 5:24 he moves the
Queen and then you get three I wish it
takes us over right Bishop takes rook
takes rook ta check check
that's over I know it's good she's got
actually 26 justing I only saw here this
is where Jack winning the Queen easily I
thought to induce a glam beat I resigned
then I then I checked there the head
also winsome okay doll Simmons
okay go to win in against mr. Killian
after he sacrificed too much so who do I
play next and we have some regular
regular guests game started some yellow
koala is on but I don't know what he's
doing what is playing you know he might
play five minute that would be cool so
I'm getting a English here and h5
against mr. Austin's Austin's
that I diss on the wall actually this is
a city this is funny for F for koalas
five minute railing is to 768 isn't that
the weirdest position ever I totally I
totally love this this opening is just
completely completely wacky black black
has played all the pawns here h 5 h 4f v
g5 f 4 I don't know it looks really
really weird idea but it limits White's
pieces we should not take that too
lightly and yeah anyway what to do I
should have did it should develop and
now the highest 5 minute ratings ever
worked like 2900 I think I am gather the
you were lost
south of XM t cow and and I learn degree
shook the IE takes it yeah this is a
very wacky position and I would be very
tempted if I'm wide to sacrifice on her
form
now koala is perfectly good at blitz
this is just not right he is also like
top top 10 top 15 and it's just not a
specialist um okay so yeah mm-hmm no my
king is weak this looks
not good
okay so so look e7 is what he wants to
do and then check me here
as extremely tough position and probably
not very good for me I had an idea with
night fg8 this one for sign comes there
and now I actually get some stuff going
myself with 95 and queen F form so this
yeah 96 oh I didn't think of this one
but I have this more here if I didn't
plan this before but it is it is there
okay
now 93 is in the mix
and screen f4 I did
I can just take air for actually it's
nothing particularly wrong with it or is
it I don't know
okay so I've gotten some stuff back
position is still totally wacky Queen to
g4 in to h5 business could have taken
only four maybe I wouldn't be surprised
if I had something good
check check
I was extremely stupid
check-check
I want to make it wrong his root
position is so bad I can I cannot be
better
I cannot be worse airily time morning
okay check what am i doing I'm kind of I
hate this I hate this game
I keep overlooking something some stuff
at it so easy to see it's really
creating awful
check draw is really not acceptable
grah offered mom odd Ron yeah that
should never is never not winders even
in I mean there are no comment
it was just totally bogus this game but
it was funny I guess what did I go up
there
what said necessary I had to hear
I will how lucky can you be Anna to
jackal there many did not see this one
bit
maybe Bishop F to him very weird game
started
okay so count no draw I have never
played a drawing as a stray and five
wins and 5 losses so let's see how we
get this line again and it was stupid
to quickly played yeah but okay he plays
some some irrelevant stuff awesome
Ruki 897 actually was interesting now I
once had a discussion about this line
with Joe Benjamin and Joe said that this
line should never be anything white and
I totally disagreed
like in this position because I have a
fantastic score with its I'm going on
almost all my tournament games with it
so let's see what mr. quant is up to
lose this Wow I am not titled I mean can
be good players it really happens I mean
I've had accounts on ICC that didn't
have my back then my FMN and I've been
to 2500 on those accounts and more than
once more than once
yeah he allowed this and somehow it
doesn't matter which is weird but yeah
five is actually playable for black
yeah summer I don't have anything here
somehow
[Music]
maybe with night h4 I can get something
going on the light squares or kg5 the
right mode take is heaven I take it a 7
King f7 check when the piece is seven
bishops e6 95 Bishop bag check
this is the camera that always drives me
crazy how can this be played in one
second and I really hope it doesn't work
again I can worship c6 every night g5 is
stronger now g5 we should be aid check
bishop at 7:00 a.m. that wins apiece
check quite primordium so that does the
trick
check
I'm not winning I don't I don't believe
this [ __ ] really I crazy was slightly
sighs better so then I have to check on
g6
this is friggin insane
to teach you five what's the deal what
what's going on yeah I don't get it I
don't understand this
what if I couldn't you take
I mean I would have really wanted this
opposite colored bishops ending but yeah
still can be weird and ok how to do this
you can put this here midnight is not
dead well-placed actually should
probably put it only three so check at
five
this is actually not check that's made
him
checkmate that's a nice one okay there
was a completely weird game I mean what
I would what I was thinking with I'm
kind of curious here should I do this
then we should be eight check here and
then this wins empty I guess because now
I'm I have to check here okay so and if
he goes here
and probably it is probably also linear
because I can actually this is probably
winning and okay
probably but still them okay
got a new request out it's really
unfortunate that Larry is not playing
anymore Larry Christian one that was
always super funny game game started
such a cetera or something so what does
he do we get into umber oxy does not
want them Roxy rather some second-rate
baloney I mean those those positions are
always playable for lecture they never
really really okay
Oh Larry stop playing a long time ago at
least there with an account that I know
you never know where you might have some
some accounts other accounts but it
probably was before I started to play an
play on video Larry has the lemme see
account and he's got the Vaska account I
mostly played against him on that when
he used the the Boscombe okay so age
five is a move that really I don't I did
not expect
no can't sing a song it's a funny idea
so let's see can we how can I get more
pressure against this I don't know if I
should play Bishop d3 and traders later
I'm doing all unsure about okay okay
what we'll take now
oh my goodness if that works I'm
stopping this stream right away I mean
what and howhow did she decide on that
in half a second
again ith four looks a bit weird but
it's so I mean really I mean yes
absolutely no attacking pieces how is
that supposed to work I don't get it
really how is that supposed to work
I should never work
which I know he goes back in it's
certainly the point of the sacrifice but
my problem is I'm a little bit behind
clockwise okay um I should probably get
some pieces over g5 doesn't work anyway
f5 is a huge hole okay I can go f3 even
everything is covered
you
now here's a chick but the quiz queen
doesn't have squares right if I do this
he has to trade Queens let's do it
check
I mean I'm giving away between which is
not ideal but let's see how to do it
the bishop should go to a forum and I'm
happy to have to have this end control
you five should a for coming and covers
g4
oh sorry this is actually attacked check
check
grave truck the Queen it's not - hi
morning check
not entirely impossible I only have one
corn left that's a problem a real
problem
and now my pawn is quick really quick
but surprised that you'll notice okay
where's the maid
check check check check
there's a checkmate somewhere right if
there isn't that would be weird I don't
see it I don't see it check check
I mean here where's the maid Queen did
too it's nice no maid
check-check
I don't see a chick bag check
can you see this always snipey three now
right 93 is coming check step made by
the way don't check
check checkmate Wow
I did have a maid in one earlier I like
that that stuff okay
one more game started and Yoshiki
the final game I've got mr. Yoshiki
always ready for full chaos let's see
maybe I can play something solid against
him I hadn't made earlier a possible I
don't know I saw one at the end and I'm
happy
I animate as possible okay I believe you
my school gets your shake by the way
this is game 31 10 lost 15 four drawers
yeah I got some pressure here 95 me
and probably probably good good for
white probably like that's a decision
that and maybe could have spent a moment
on but well so and he's got these chicks
and take about Knight f5 still I mean
this is such a big juicy square so if
you place that I mean I'm just playing
on this 93 business just taking a gamble
that the games against them get into
some sort of chaos anyway so might as
well do it immediately go for chaos this
this 23 Bishop f5 Bishop f4 is
interesting okay so maybe discover it
okay yeah so Bishop at five now Bishop
before takes Queen takes I've got I've
got the night cover that was one idea
book ca8 oh I will probably have to take
it's okay though okay now the maid of
course I have to do something what I was
about to play age six by the way which
is a little bit non precise
I wonder if Knight takes e5 is actually
a threat Knight takes Queen takes rook
e8 and his queen is trapped
Seppo so let me check 9525 rook e8 he
has Queen h8 I will that this world mine
anything else she looks too tempting to
not Flay it actually so Queen takes root
create a twin s no squares it's only
Queen h8 but that
well it isn't actually that clear but I
have B 5 c4 come on
check-check Frankie right so I think I
go here to not be in the in the
immediate checks and so on so I take
with this and now B 5c form I hope that
those pawns are strong I mean they are
strong
it's just that are they strong enough
rookie 897 if I take with the king isn't
that good
he's out for f4 I guess I still have c3
things and it isn't it isn't super clear
is is clearing this but if I go look b8
where is he going
we should see one light situation look
trap and ice okay as I overlook this I'm
really overlooked it still would be one
maybe we should take stage takes pawn
takes rook F 3 c3 would be three hooks
III and he cannot stop it okay
so you know night see - I know what that
does
who does he actually stop that I don't
think he does it's not clear that I'm
winning with time warning
okay it's just a couple of checks check
so the question is can I can I get a
full queen probably not let's let's do
this check
I forgot you can take the pawn
immediately check check
kara Alfred
draw Alfred I'm just checking aware of
some trickery on the edge of the board
check I don't have any check draw all
chat game drawn I cannot do much there
look at night this is really pretty
pretty useless but tough Warner always
interesting games against your cheek
okay guys I hope you enjoyed the show
I'll be back next week with some more
hopefully entertaining blitz games yeah
I am glad that the technical side of
things worked out well and yeah I'm
happy to be back next week thanks y'all
thank you all for watching bye bye
you